[Music]
on this wednesday night as covid 19
cases drop anxiety rises over variance
today's variant count is the tip
of an iceberg the calls to delay
reopening in ontario
as newfoundland struggles to contain a
growing outbreak hundreds of healthcare
workers self-isolate
and labradora calls for a bubble
multiplying cases
in classrooms the reassurances i would
be that concerned
plus the potential threat of variants
combining to create
hybrid mutations and no power
no heat it was eight degrees in the
house and no mercy in texas from a cold
snap
including for thousands of sea turtles
saved from certain death
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a good news bad news
scenario playing out in canada right now
the good news canada is making major
progress reducing the spread of cobit
19.
after peaking at more than 8 000 daily
new cases in january
infections have now fallen to below 3000
a day
the bad news highly contagious new
variants are gaining ground
they have been detected in all 10
provinces in canada's largest city 56
variant cases have been confirmed and
hundreds of possible cases are awaiting
confirmation in labs
in nearby peel region there are 45
confirmed variant cases
the top doctors for both regions say now
is not the time for their cities to
reopen
they are calling for the lockdown to be
extended until at least march
9th and they are crystal clear about why
the variants are spreading and stopping
them may well be impossible
but let's at least slow them for a
little while longer until
more vaccine is available i have never
been
as worried about the future as i am
today right now the case counts
the case count numbers don't look so bad
they don't sound bad but today's
variant count is the tip of an iceberg
by the time the confirmed case counts
are big enough to shock us
it will be too late to do anything
we will be in a third wave as bad as
anything we've been through thus far
in newfoundland and labrador it is
already worse than it's ever been before
in the span of two weeks the number of
active cases in that province has jumped
from 14
to 338. 44 new cases were confirmed
today
it's believed the spike has been driven
by the uk variant
as ross lord reports in tonight's top
story the outbreak is having ripple
effects
across the province among the thousands
of people forced to self-isolate in
newfoundland and labrador
are many who'd normally be on the front
lines of the battle against covet 19.
over 500 health care workers throughout
newfoundland and labrador
presently isolating related to
either context for positive cases or
possible contacts or symptoms
some others are home because they have
no child care while nurses
scrambling to administer 2 000 covet
tests a day
are doing so without vaccinations
according to their union
even our team that are swabbing
the past week or so are not vaccinated
in a letter to the health minister and
the province's chief medical officer
the union urges them to take all
measures to speed the vaccination
process
the outbreak from the variant first
identified in the uk
is having other ripple effects far
outside the saint john's area
a part of the province that sometimes
feels left out is now
asking for isolation leaders in labrador
which is separated from newfoundland by
geography
and has a larger indigenous population
are calling for their own bubble
to keep outbreaks in st john's or
anywhere else from infecting
their communities officials in wabush
say it's time for mandatory rapid
testing
or at least self-isolation for visitors
from the island of newfoundland
to keep their town coveted free we just
want to make sure that anybody come here
especially from a known area where the
cases are
are happening i don't think it's too
much to ask
that somebody isolate or have the
testing jitters
created by the outbreak are hard to
brush aside with health authorities
warning it could be a while before
fluctuating case counts
subside ross lord global news
there is still lots of uncertainty about
how the variants impact
children and are transmitted within
schools students in parts of ontario
have recently returned to classrooms
in alberta schools have been in session
for weeks and nearly a dozen are now
reporting exposure to the variant first
discovered in the uk
heather urich's west looks at what it
could mean for the weeks ahead
the return to in-person learning brings
a sense of relief for this toronto
parent
i love my kids to death but they're
starting to drive me crazy
though david wood admits he worries
about the impact of new
covid variants in alberta where schools
have been open to in-person learning
since early january
there have now been exposures to the
variant that first emerged in the uk
in at least nine schools and in school
transmission has been found
in at least three in a small number
we're seeing a small handful of
secondary cases but again no
large exposure events in schools still
dr dina hinshaw says the new
variant does not appear to be spreading
in schools any differently than
the original virus i wouldn't be that
concerned i don't think anybody
expects there to be no transmission in
schools
dr martha fulford says since the
beginning of the pandemic schools have
reflected the amount of viral activity
in the community
and have not appeared to contribute to a
rise in cases
the other really important thing is
trying to balance what we're trying to
achieve and children fortunately even
with all the new variants
do not get severe disease from covert
it's true few children have had to be
hospitalized because of coven 19 in
canada
and less than five have died though
there is still much about covet 19's
long-term
impact on kids that just isn't known but
it's not just
the health of students at stake variants
have been shown to spread more
easily among household contacts even if
there's
you know only a few cases at a school
then you know let's say it
has a high attack rate in the household
and then you know the
one of the parents works at a meat
processing facility
it's all connected right it's all a
chain it's why alberta is now asking
anyone who tests
positive for the variant to isolate away
from household contacts
at a government provided hotel heather
urex west global news
calgary there is some good news tonight
about canada's vaccine supply after
being delayed yesterday by bad weather
in the u.s
pfizer says its scheduled shipments to
canada are back on track
the company says just over 345 000 doses
of the pfizer biotech vaccine were
delivered today
58 000 more are expected to be delivered
by friday
the vaccine rollout in first nation
metis and inuit communities is happening
faster than in much of the rest of the
country
according to the latest data more than
83 000 vaccine doses have been
administered to people and more than
400 indigenous communities 25 percent of
indigenous adults have received at least
one dose
that is about six times the rate of the
rest of the country
indigenous services minister mark miller
says he is worried about the risk
from the new variants
it's scary and it is indicating a a
larger
spread or potential to spread
and that's just magnified when you when
you superimpose all the conditions that
exist in
indigenous communities scientists are
learning about these new variants
in real time and though there is still
much uncertainty
some evidence is emerging two of them
have combined
to form a mutated hybrid the journal new
scientists reported on the research
which was done
at los alamos national lab in the u.s
it's not
known if this hybrid poses a bigger
threat but as eric sorensen reports it
is a sign the virus is constantly
keeping
a step ahead of us it was an
underappreciated feature of the pandemic
a virus that spread to all corners of
the world would inevitably spawn
mutations
and as it transmitted through millions
of people variants appeared within
months of the original covet 19 outbreak
now potentially another evolution from
virus
to variant to hybrid variant derived
from two mutated viruses
this is not going to be a simple uh
virus a perfectly straightforward you
know one time and done
i think these are things that the
scientists are going to be watching
closely
we should respect them but i think
there's no reason to panic
when the novel coronavirus emerged the
simple hope was for a vaccine to kill it
as with any virus it mutated into
countless variants
most are not threatening but variants of
concern
first spotted in the uk south africa
brazil
and now california have emerged capable
in some cases of spreading more quickly
now from a u.s lab reports of a
recombinant virus the uk and california
variants together
creating a hybrid mutation perhaps even
more resistant
and less familiar to the original
vaccines the more
virus you have out there in the world
and the more
variants there are allowed to mix the
greater and
greater chances you are taking of
something
brewing that becomes extremely dangerous
mutations often weaken a virus but in a
pandemic so widespread
some variants are proving more
transmissible it will force vaccine
researchers and manufacturers to keep
up we don't know whether these variants
will continue to evolve where it gets to
the point where the current vaccines
that we have
are no longer sufficiently effective
scientists say the best approach right
now
is to blunt the spread of the original
virus to reduce opportunities for
mutations
it doesn't mean life can't get back to
normal relatively soon
in the future yes we may have to get
booster shots with a slightly altered
vaccine
as the virus continues to change but
this is very similar to what we see with
influenza
in the meantime a scientific game of cat
and mouse is underway
as the virus changes and humans try to
adapt
eric sorensen global news toronto
now to london and news about prince
philip the 99 year old husband of the
queen is in the hospital tonight
the palace says it is not an emergency
situation that he was admitted as a
precaution
our europe bureau chief crystal
gamansing is keeping an eye on
developments
for us prince philip the duke of
edinburgh will spend at least a couple
of nights
here at the king edward the 7th hospital
it's not your typical
clinical looking facility it's tucked
into a normally
quiet residential london neighborhood
it's not known what's wrong with the 99
year old but we know
it is not covid19 prince philip and the
queen received their vaccinations
last month according to a short
statement from buckingham palace he had
been feeling
unwell for a few days it's reported he
was taken
from windsor castle by car not ambulance
to the hospital in london
where it said he walked into the
facility under his own power
underscoring what the palace is calling
a precautionary stay
as word spread about his hospitalization
media from around the world
began gathering prince philip retired
from active royal duty
in 2017 in december of 2019
just like now the world was on edge when
he was admitted to the very same
facility
the prince's health is top of mind for
many in britain
prime minister boris johnson sent his
best wishes to the duke
prince phillip will turn 100 in june and
while an
active otherwise healthy individual his
age
is a concern the palace says while he's
here he will be observed
and get some rest crystal gomanson
global news
london nothing is sacred it seems for
some people who troll
others online the daughter of captain
sir tom moore
the war veteran who raised millions of
pounds for britain's national health
service
says she shielded him from online abuse
in the weeks before he died
she says her father faced outrageous
negativity after a family trip to
barbados in december
she says the family kept the offensive
messages a secret because they feared
they would break his heart captain tom
struck a cord with his record-breaking
walk around his garden
100 laps before his 100th birthday and
he raised tens of millions of dollars
for health care workers caring for cobit
19 patients
moore received floods of supportive
messages and
so many cards on his 100th birthday they
filled the hall
of his grandson's school his daughter
refuses to let the haters ruin
what he did i couldn't
i couldn't tell him because how do you
rationalize to a hundred year old man
that
something so incredibly good can attract
such horror
so we contained it within the four of us
and we
said they that we won't play to them
we're not talking to those
vile minority a 35 year old scottish man
charged with tweeting an offensive
message has pleaded not guilty
moore died on february 2nd he'd been
fighting pneumonia and had tested
positive
for covet 19. millions of texans are
bracing for another
cold dark night coming up why officials
say they have to keep the electricity
off
plus demolishing an eyesore a former
landmark
crumbles
onlookers cheered as the former trump
plaza hotel and casino in atlantic city
new jersey imploded today it took seven
seconds and
three thousand sticks of dynamite to
bring down the complex that opened back
in nineteen eighty four
former u s president donald trump lost
control of the site in 2009 in a
bankruptcy
it shut down five years later in its
heyday it was
atlantic city's premier casino
in parts of texas power is still off as
that deadly deep freeze
holds its grip tonight nearly 3 million
homes are without power and without heat
makeshift shelters have been set up to
keep people warm
as jackson protzko reports with no clue
when the rolling blackouts will be over
there could be
more cold nights ahead first came the
deep freeze
now an ice storm just as millions of
texans start another day in the dark
do you have a reason to think that you
could lose power again at any moment
oh for sure i'm actually very surprised
that i have had it
for four hours now rachel mccormick is
canada's consul general in dallas
she her husband and their two young
girls are on their fourth day of long
rolling blackouts it was eight degrees
in the house eight degrees celsius in
the house
the houses here just aren't built like
they are in canada right
and a lot of people are having problems
with pipes freezing
with the power out the basics of life
fade away
many places have no water those that do
advise people to boil it the lines for
groceries are growing ever longer
we're just trying to get something to
eat for now with the crisis still
unfolding
the state's governor has tried to blame
frozen wind turbines for the disaster
our wind and our solar got shut down it
was in fact
natural gas and coal plants that failed
the state grid is so
fragile in cold conditions officials
insist they had no choice
but to keep the power off if we had
allowed
instead of going for these outages to
allow a catastrophic blackout to occur
that could be four months the outages
could last into next week
we're just hoping that the lights will
come back soon enough
because it's really freezing it's
horrible as people desperately try to
stay warm
a growing number are dead from carbon
monoxide poisonings
and there are growing questions about
why texas wasn't better prepared
jackson prosko global news washington
rush limbaugh a talk radio megastar has
died
they're deathly afraid that trump is
going to triumphantly return to public
life
the russian bus show was on the air for
more than three decades the
controversial and
influential host was at the mic right up
until earlier this month as he was being
treated for lung cancer
he was a staunch ally of former
president donald trump who awarded him
the presidential medal of freedom in
2020.
trump spoke about limbaugh today in his
first interview since leaving office
to those people that listened to him
every day like
it was like a religious experience for a
lot of people i mean
his fans they just wouldn't miss him
a very very unique person
limbaugh's widow catherine delivered the
news of his passing on his radio show
thanking listeners for their support
rush limbaugh was 70 years old
johnson and johnson jab still ahead
south africa starts inoculations with a
world first
you're watching global national
japan's fight against covid19 took a
major step today the first vaccinations
began frontline healthcare workers are
first in line to get the pfizer buy in
tech shot
japan's vaccine approval process has
been slower than other major economies
because of deep-rooted concerns about
safety plus a requirement to conduct
domestic clinical trials
vaccinations are seen as critical to
holding a successful
summer olympics the games have already
been delayed a year
because of the pandemic south africa's
vaccination campaign is pivoting in an
effort to get the highly contagious
variant first identified in that country
under control
health care workers and government
officials including the president were
the first to roll up their sleeves and
get the single dose johnson and johnson
vaccine
it's still in the trial phase and hasn't
been approved anywhere in the world
south africa suspended its rollout of
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine after
data showed it gave little protection
against this south african variant
what do elon musk texas and sea turtles
have in common
next a remarkable rescue story
the deep freeze in texas is terribly
hard on people of course but wildlife
is suffering too sea turtles are a
federally protected and
endangered species and the beaches on
the gulf of mexico are a key breeding
ground for them
as mike drale reports right now
thousands of them need human help
to survive everything they say
is bigger in texas that apparently now
includes winter storms
the polar vortex has stunned more than
just texans in the gulf of mexico
turtles are experiencing what's called
cold stun which is when their body
temperatures fall so low
they essentially get paralyzed leaving
them unable to eat or even hold their
heads above the water
a local conservation group called sea
turtle inc called for help
volunteers loaded the stun reptiles into
their cars the rescue center filled up
as of the convention center
with more than 4 thousand turtles but
they were managing
and at the nearby san antonio zoo
officials were downright
confident they could weather the storm
it's nothing unique or special
but then the unthinkable happened the
power grid the one thing not big enough
in texas
gave out and after animals froze to
death at a nearby sanctuary
the zoo filled its one heated building
with alligators and flamingos
the cold wasn't helping the frozen
turtles situation either
so sea turtle inc put out a plea for
help on social media
and a neighbor noticed
that neighbor just happens to be
billionaire elon musk
who owns the nearby spacex launch pad he
called in the middle of the night
and by morning a massive commercial
generator was on site
they came to us in our darkest hour of
need
and found a generator that was complex
to find
and even more complex to wire into our
system
and that would be a great ending to the
story except all their pool heaters
fried with the power outage
but at least they can supply some warmth
to the turtles
and give them a better shot at surviving
the texas chill
microlight global news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is the sun setting in dieppe
new brunswick
there are beautiful spots all over
canada please email us yours to viewers
at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you